rampage how do you think uh john would
do at heavyweight
jon jones yeah man i think john jones
one of the best fighters in the world oh
ever i i think uh i think he'll do do um
good against like the um smaller
heavyweights but you don't think you do
well against like francis or yeah cyril
gone i think i think he'll take francis
down and and you know so i think he
probably would
but i think if he get hit if he gets hit
one problem he i think if he get i think
if he gets hit once he'll probably get
knocked out of that weight class yeah i
always wanted something like jon jones
if you're a fighter and you're taking
that much time off yeah does that [ __ ]
with your head he's doing it to build
his body that's what he says but then
he's also doing it because he wants his
pay to fight the biggest heavyweight
fight of all time i'm gonna tell you
something about jon jones what i noticed
about him and i noticed it too late
after i fought him
hit his mind it's his mind his mind is
is really strong when when i fought john
jones i i honestly underestimated him
because i was in really good shape and i
wasn't i didn't have any injuries a
little knee injury that wasn't that bad
back then but i've i've never lost a
fight in that good of a shape i was in
colorado training and i was training for
a couple of months my cardio was meant i
was in i was in probably like one of the
best shapes i've ever been and i was
just like there's no way i'm losing to
this kid but his mind is so strong
what do you mean by that what do you
mean like what do you mean by it he has
no weakness like like no matter how the
fight's going yeah he did he didn't
falter there's no quit ever yeah forever
and like he's so strong mentally like
when he fought ryan bader or gus finn he
barely trained like gus finn it was a
five-round war war like war he barely
trained for that fight like but he goes
in the fight believing that he's the
best in the world but here's the thing
you i want you i want people to remember
this is when he fought chao
he got through that round with his
[ __ ] foot right his toe ripped out
his bone was sticking out of the front
they actually panned down they actually
had to stop it they tried to cut it yeah
they tried to click like clip away from
it they didn't realize his toe was
facing this way and the bone was
sticking out straight he looked down he
didn't even realize until after the
round and then he looked down he's like
he almost passed out you could tell he
was sick to his stomach by looking at
his [ __ ] he's so focused but he was
so focused on beating chael he got
through the first the rest of the
round some people believe in and the
power of the mind like being mentally
strong some people believe in it and if
you if you tell yourself something that
you really believe in and you and you
have
no doubt you can do it and that's what
jon jones is his mind is really strong
like i don't think john's like i mean
he's good at everything but he's not
like great at everything it's his is his
mentality but he's hey he's he's like
the dirtiest fighter he's the dirtiest
fighter
someone told me that no no no no but i
haven't seen it honestly you haven't
seen this
when i fought him whenever i was
whenever i was like have any type of
advantage he he'll put his fingers in my
eye
let me do this right how uncomfortable
is this right here that man that's uncle
your eyeball is your weakest thing on
your body right so when i was fighting
he was like this the whole time it's
hard to train for this too
so
he said that he poked me he poked me i
didn't then then and then when you come
in and advance you kick your knee
backwards and you don't you know they
should make that they should make that
illegal you know your parents tell you
like you don't touch your sister don't
let your brother like i used to do this
[ __ ] i'm not touching you oh my god
he's talking about the john jones [ __ ]
right yeah to your point eyes are the
most i don't even [ __ ] how tall the nuts
you're right
eyes are terrible yeah yeah yeah there's
a slightly little piece of dust in your
hand god damn game over there
one of these just go shut up
yeah
every time i every time i got any type
of advantage that i that the hand was in
he poked me and i he poked my eye once
or twice in the fight but and training
camera on my last bar and i already had
like you know the little red blood
vessel because somebody poked me in iron
training camp because we was trying to
train for that [ __ ] and if you can't
train for it no you can't train for it
so i remember i was i was already [ __ ]
up yeah yeah it so it was really it was
really hard fighting him so if anybody
get any advantage on him he's going to
kick your knee backwards and keep you
away and he's going to figure it out
he's going to figure it out that need
that front kick they should make that
illegal yeah that's stupid that's so
stupid yeah i think it's it's starting
with you really right yeah yeah yeah
it's more than everyone copyrighted
and you know there's just no need for it
no need for it isn't it how sarah gone
won just one like that yeah he does that
that's a muay thai thing i think they do
that a lot like they just he like they
get away with it by saying it's like a
what uh uh uh what they call they trying
to say the front kicks
and they try and push your leg but it's
actually your knee yeah i'm trying to i
i've always thought you should that that
i don't like that it should be illegal
it should be illegal but well because
the same thing that you got to protect
the product so like in the nfl they made
it legal to hit quarterbacks below the
knees the tom brady rule yeah so it
should be illegal to somebody has a
whole bunch of rules though the tuck
rule the knee ring yeah but it's still
about what about kicks
that's it so that that you but you but
it's not going to end your career from a
calf kick that
so you'd make that illegal 100 yeah